and that's a scheme
but i know that length of my arm
he can't penetrate me on the six of
earth
[Music]
so i know that i'm safe so this is
called my distance
what happens is i see people do that wow
on the third down i've been there done
it now right so so about 10 minutes into
the train
it'll end up back here without knowing
it i'll say it and i'll go oh yeah
they've gone back to the old routine
safety numbers you know
so
it sounds the silly thing but if you
could just keep
doing that and you'll find that you'll
go
i didn't think i was ill
so it's repetition until you get the
body going
the head and toe theory that i have
personally is when he lives it's as if a
bit of string was on his ken and that
lifted my hand
so i can watch all of you he can lift
and i'll go
[Music]
because i've been doing it right
but but for now i've got to use my bit
my eyes i'm going to look at these
chests rather than these eyes
and
that's how i'm getting the timing so
coming down
so you've got two things so you've got
taken from the what we take from the
weapons to improve our tightness
i shouldn't be thinking too much i
should work out
are you seeing this watch
i tread it down i don't do hit reviews
like you know i didn't like it so i
didn't follow him but he
almost starts a motorbike you know with
this and since he said if they see your
legs move they know you're moving where
you're coming
i just want you to see that
that you're
entering
about here i want you to be about here
a clever person would say albert said so
you could cut you
but i'm not into butts i'm into let's do
a section at a time
i need to be here to do taxidermy
because that hand
is going to go in there
if the hand goes in here
and i do that um
i need the use of that
and i'm not going to have to attach a
doorway
so that's why
at the very beginning
i don't like captain dory because most
people do it and get not a lot out of it
only because i'm doing it here if i was
doing it there
this would be up
all right just here
times each bring it
straight ahead bring it down
i need you to be at this end
okay please try